this video is sponsored by audible we
all like a good story don't we
what if i told you that our friends over
at audible will read thousands of
stories to you at the touch of a button
you can listen to their professional
narrators narrate whatever audiobooks
you choose anytime
anywhere from any device making any time
story time a recent pew study revealed
that a tragic
27 percent of adults haven't read a
single book in the past
year due to being too busy as the main
reason but audible is here to help and
put the love of stories back into our
lives
and it's easier now than it's ever been
as people transition to the new living
at home
normal these days audible cared enough
to create several
100 free audio services that really make
me happy
stories.audible.com features hundreds of
audiobooks available from any device
for no cost or sign up i'm not kidding
you can
literally just visit the website and
click on a title and some super
attractive sounding person will start
reading it to you so please
do yourself a favor and check out their
completely free services at
stories.audible.com and for those of you
who are interested in their complete
collection of thousands of titles and
immediate access to all
audible originals or even daily news
digests from places like the wall street
journal
you can sign up for their membership
with the free trial by visiting
audible.com
mnb or texting mnb to 500 500
with your fancy cellular phone device
once again that is audible.com
mnb or text mnb to 500 500
and speaking of stories why don't we
have a listen to one of the greatest
legends
ever told once upon a time there was a
kingdom called hyrule in this kingdom
there lived a beautiful princess
and her name was zelda the kingdom
thrived
blessed with good wealth and prosperity
from the goddesses above
until one day when a primal evil arose
from the depths of the earth
and threatened the very existence of
good
all over the possession of the kingdom's
most valued relic
the omnipotent triforce however when
evil seemingly overpowered good
and all hope was nearly lost for hyrule
and its princess
a hero appeared wielding a legendary
blade capable of extinguishing
all traces of evil from the land and
this hero's name
was link together he and the princess
would prevent
the corruption of the triforce and expel
evil once and for all
leaving the kingdom its princess and the
hero to live on for a very well deserved
happily ever after
until it all happened again and again
and again you see this primal evil had a
source and that source
had a name demise the king of the demons
is the individual who is solely
responsible for the conception of
evil and the beginning of the cycle by
which evil continues to regain
form time and time again whether it's by
way of an evil wizard a gerudo king
or the literal manifestation of hatred
eventually
even the people of hyrule caught on to
the pattern of this cycle and decided to
take preventative measures against it
which was successful for a time but as
we've all seen in the most recent title
breath of the wild this malicious hatred
found a way around even the most cunning
of hylian plans
in a world where no amount of years or
millennia can prevent the returning of
evil in a seemingly eternal cycle
is there any hope for permanent peace in
hyrule is there any way to end
the cycle
yep there is well okay maybe there is
now this is gonna be a theory that's
pretty darn speculative and mostly a
what if kind of scenario but it's pretty
incredible to think about
at least for me also in this video i'm
kind of
only talking about games that feature
the master sword or the original magical
sword for this theory so the games
featuring the four sword or the phantom
sword will be considered a different
cycle in this specific video
so anyway let's get into it long long
ago demise initially coveted the
triforce right
you know that all-powerful relic created
by the goddesses themselves for the sole
purpose of granting wishes and starting
wars
like this one and that desire of his is
somehow burned into the minds of all
future incarnations of his evil like
ganon for instance
ganon's one and only desire every time
he appears
is to use the triforce to blot out the
light and create a world of darkness
that he
alone will rule this means that ganon's
desire is an extension of demise himself
but if we remember what happened to
demise at the end of the game skyward
sword
it's clear that his essence was sucked
into the master sword and there he began
to deteriorate according to fee
this is all well and good but have you
ever wondered how exactly demise's
hatred is incarnating over and over
again to create the other demons like
ganon
i mean we know he cursed the royal
family in the spirit of the hero
as we see in his dying words but what
does that actually mean
like what are the mechanics of this
whole thing did he just utter a curse to
the wind to create more demons every
couple thousands of years
how was that being fulfilled are there
other demons taking up the mantle in
order to maintain his curse's
credibility
how did his curse create the cycle well
i think we can gather a very important
clue to the nature of this curse
by looking at what we know gannon who is
a reincarnation of demise
can do fast forward to the prologue
section of the wind waker which details
the return of ganon who was previously
sealed away following the adult timeline
ending of ocarina of time the fact that
he busted out of his seal is what i'd
like to draw attention to
you see sometimes ganon does have help
from his followers to be resurrected
but in this case it just took an unknown
yet large amount of time and ganon was
able to
actually legitimately build enough power
to burst out of his seal and terrorize
the world once again
although that one may actually be able
to be chalked up to the fact that he had
the triforce of power
already in his possession following the
events of ocarina of time but
this also is not the only time we see
ganon growing in power until he can
break out of the seal either in the most
recent game breath of the wild
calamity ganon was defeated and then
literally takes ten
thousand years to grow in power in order
to once again
break out of his seal and terrorize the
world we have at this point
no idea where the triforce of power is
and in fact many people theorize
zelda to actually have the full triforce
within herself somehow which is not
really what i believe but either way we
have no proof that calamity gannon was
able to build power via the triforce of
power and return to terrorize hyrule 10
000 years later
so where is his power coming from you
might be tempted to say it's coming from
the ganondorf corpse
but where is that power coming from why
is this power
so undying and undefeatable when demise
has been so
completely defeated in the past does
this mean that the reincarnations of
demise like ganon are actually more
powerful than demise was
himself well no i don't think so and
this is what i'm getting at
what if demise is not actually dead
i mean breath of the wild proves that
phi is still alive within the sword
so why not demise as well haven't you
ever wondered why the master sword
continually has its power drained and
has to be powered back up
over time a little strange for the bane
of evil's bane don't you think
what if demise is actually behind that
and is able to build his power from
within the master sword
inside of which he is sealed and thus
weaken the sword and create the new
demon kings we've been fighting across
tens of thousands of years like the many
incarnations of ganon what if these are
all creations of demise himself
who is single-handedly keeping the cycle
alive from within the sword which would
mean that the sages the princesses the
demons the heroes and the sword itself
are all tied to the cycle because demise
isn't
dead but since demise has been sealed
away and nobody can really touch him
how could we possibly stop the cycle
that he's continually fueling
allow me to answer this question with
another question how do you stop a river
from flowing or an
arrow from flying or a bloodline from
continuing
okay that last one was pretty dark
granted but in each scenario
you go to the source and cut it off in
this case
to stop demise's power from seeping into
the world over and over again
what if his prison the master sword has
to be destroyed while he's inside
the way i see it this could go one of
two ways one if the master sword was
broken
it could release demise into the world
which would now exist without the master
sword
that would be a bummer but two the
master sword could destroy the souls
that live inside it
fee and demise freeing the world from
the hateful cycle once and for all
now i'm not saying that this is
something i expect to happen in a future
game or even that i want to see
happen because i kind of really like the
master sword this is all
completely a what-if kind of scenario
like i mentioned earlier on in the video
but doesn't it kinda make sense if
demise is still alive within the master
sword that makes sense as to why hylia
created it to seal him in the first
place as he was initially her
enemy and it also makes sense as to why
the master sword is the only weapon
capable of defeating demise's evil
creations but if link could use the
master sword to defeat the current
incarnation of demise and then destroy
the sword
what if that is what it would take to
end the cycle
once and for all and that is my theory
on how to end the cycle of hatred that
governs the legend of zelda did you
enjoy the video
if so please leave a like and comment
below what your aha
moment was or if you think i missed
something or you know if you think i'm
just crazy
and also please consider subscribing to
not only stick around but also to help
grow the channel and reach more
zelda fans just like you and me as
always huge thanks to you for watching
and to my fantastic supporters who make
my day
every day the new faces for this video
are joshua c
and mnd who both decided to support the
channel right here on youtube by
clicking that join button below
every video if you're interested in
joining the ranks of my elite crew
and helping the next video come to life
follow that same join button located
below
every video or visit the links in the
description to find out how
also real quick i have some amazing fan
art to show off from a
very talented individual that i am very
grateful to have in my discord server
named
rini and isn't this just the cutest they
even used my favorite costumes from
breath of the wild
come over to my server and say hi to
rinnie and the rest of us and yours
truly by visiting the link in the
description below
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day
this is masentana bandit signing out
[Music]
you